Berenice was his sudden resignation over
Gaza and Israel was it principled
standing or poisonous grandstanding
Douglas I think you rather think the
latter I do rather think that long time
now well-known the bonus was he's been
unhappy about not being promoted about
being fobbed off with pretend jobs and
many jobs and bits of other people's
jobs
she has expected in a number of
reshuffles indeed when the coalition was
formed to get the ministry of her own to
run she was never given that of course
and has become I think more and more
disgruntled it was always an effort at
some point she would have a fallout not
least because she has for some time been
running effectively a parallel set of
policies to those of the prime ministers
on the counter extremism agenda she's
very narrowly missed being sacked on a
number of occasions other political
winds have happened to blow and stop
that from happening so I don't think
this is a great surprise and I don't
think it is in fact about what she says
it is if she was genuinely concerned
about the British government's non
statements as she thinks they are over
Gaza she would have first of all had a
better opportunity to voice them by
being inside the cabinet than by being
outside and secondly it's a very strange
time to do it um she made her great
grandstanding moment at the moment that
his Raley forces the ground forces were
withdrawing from the Gaza and a peace
began
so it's very hard you don't think she I
mean you don't think there's anything
wrong with her with a with a major
conservative figure being off message as
it were on on the government's line
particularly in in a coalition
government like this one that there's
going to be a very wide range of
opinions around the table Nick Clegg has
not been particularly restrained in his
condemnation of the Israelis in recent
days the Lib Dems are kind of trying to
pay a dame killed at the moment by
saying as much as they can against the
Israeli government and are actually
going out and saying to voters look
we're we're condemning the Israelis so
so no I mean I mean I look forward to
hearing what it is she has to say in the
days and weeks ahead and how vicious she
will make it
timmi do you think the timings not a
little suspicious I think it might be I
first of all this was a very poorly
handled resignation I mean I'm I'm not
much better than myself I resigned the
same way I in relationships a very short
email and then don't pick up your phone
for two weeks but in this system if I
was gonna resign littered with
grammatically yeah no this is the link
if I was gonna resign from the
government I would get someone else to
read the letter I had written for me to
make sure that for example I hadn't
completely screwed up my grammar or
failed to put in a paragraph break or
written it in a strange alignment that
means that from a distance it looks like
a letter from British Rail telling you
that a fine is overdue as this really
weird overly humble but seriously she
may have her flaws but I think it's
significant this is the first person to
step down from the government in 11
years since 2003 on a point of principle
about foreign policies the first of all
I'm happy about that I can't believe
that there's 11 years no one's had an
issue with Iraq with Afghanistan with
Syria and I'm really impressed that
someone finally has stood up for that
regardless of the many complicated other
factors that might be involved secondly
I she's taken an enormous risk Baroness
Warsi is nothing without David Cameron
she doesn't have a seat in the House of
Commons she her political identity is
linked entirely to the cameroonian
project of trying to reach out people
don't normally vote Tory
so for her to go in this manner is to
take an enormous risk and essentially to
walk into the
and I suspect given that she has nowhere
else to go and the only other option is
the Lib Dems take her which I'm sure
even she recognizes would be a mistake
given that and given out what she's done
I say good for her it's a risk and I'm
impressed that we have a politician
prepared to take it don't listen in the
magazine this week you talked about the
West's lack of obvious leadership of a
strong moral figure to stand up for the
what used to be called the free world
yeah I mean obviously your politics are
in no way aligned with baroness wells
'yes but do you not think this is the
kind of apology as tim says this is the
kind of politics we need this is its
principle although obviously you'd think
it's cynical it doesn't form part of any
coherent policy it does fall apart she's
been fairly consistent on Israel I'd say
well we've been reading her tweets she's
actually been eating for two or three
weeks yes she's been tweeting consistent
yes one the other ones I think wasn't a
surprise if you follow her on Twitter
yes you'll see that she spent most of
her time talking about Gaza and berating
any supporters of Israel no I don't
think she has been consistent I mean she
she's always throughout her time in the
Conservative cabinet she's always and
she's always tried to be seen to be
close to the conservative friends of
Israel it's a bit of a problem for
because she has a very checkered track
record as I've written on the blog this
week on her own attitudes towards Hamas
she is awful somebody who thought and
said publicly my time as came to power
that she thought it was a great
opportunity and that Hamas would use the
opportunity to become effectively
secular Liberal Democrats
a prediction which did not pan out but
just quickly on this thing about her own
position I mean I think it's true what
Tim says no she is a she is a creation
of Cameron's she is of course in the
House of Lords and I think she'll like
Jenny Tom walk around for some time as a
one-woman demonstration of why the House
of Lords needs reform but the specific
point about wuzzies tenure so far what
she is trying to do I don't think has
been understood enough and that is this
she was brought into the Shadow Cabinet
and the camera intended for a very
tokenistic reason some ways and other
ways an important reason to show we're a
broad party we have a female Muslim
sorry she could have done an enormous
amount of good in that role she could
have shown Muslims and others around the
country what what politics was about in
Britain that it was not about identity
politics it was not about saying I as a
Muslim we as Muslims must think this our
Muslim brothers there are Muslim sisters
there it was about being a British
citizen and one of the striking things
throughout was his period in the shadow
cabinet of the cabinet
he said she transferred from being the
Muslim who happened to be in the cabinet
and Shadow Cabinet
into trying to be effectively a minister
for Muslims it was what Lord Achmed
before he ran over and killed somebody
in his car was trying to do to become
the peer who represented British Muslims
that was her ambition I think that's
going to be her ambition going forged
that's how she sees herself now and I
think it's a tragedy and a completely
wasted opportunity I think it's a little
bit unfair I think it was more nuanced
than that I think she saw herself as
someone representing people of faith
because last year for example in DC she
gave a very good speech about
persecution of Christians and indeed all
the while that she was tweeting about
her mashes also tweeting up tweeting
about the condition of Christians in
northern Iraq I think she probably
wanted to be that but that MyID may have
been a slightly naive ambition because
like it or not
identity politics does matter and in the
same way that one is a Minister for
women so one invariably it stands out
one particular gender I think the fact
that she was always signposted perhaps
unfairly by the media perhaps unfairly
by her own party as a Muslim in cabinet
at least the Muslim woman in cabinet
meant that she ended up doing that but I
think she's worth more than that and I
actually regard her as an important
eloquent and quite effective voice in
the last four years my hide the
highlight of her career for me was when
she was against the BNP on question time
and she was absolutely brilliant and
very importantly she presented a face of
middle-class and working-class Muslim
Britons who said we are British this
this fascism is an offense to us but
most importantly misrepresents what we
are and that was what she was very very
important very good I mean anybody looks
good Griffen I mean it simply they know
here's a fascist
we're not fascists we look good opposite
the fascist it never gets easier than
that